hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how Micro City can
provide insight into dynamic disease
processes which will be presented by
Professor iterative on the Velva
assistant professor at the Kay you live
in my name is Kayla Bella and the market
product manager with Brooker and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lap routes and
sponsored by broker broker enables
scientists to make breakthrough
discoveries and develop new applications
that improve the quality of human life
Rooker's high-performance scientific
instruments and high-value analytical
and diagnostic solutions enable
scientists to explore life and materials
at molecular cellular and microscopic
levels for more information please visit
the website broker com before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting a question if
you like at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button will answer as many
questions as we have signed for at the
end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support that
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
this offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit lastly at
the end of the presentation you will
receive a poll survey we currently ask
you to complete your answers and
suggestions will help to improve our
webinar program and is greatly
appreciated now I would like to
introduce our presenter professor
creative and develop professor Rhonda
Velma is an assistant professor in
imaging and pathology at the universe
of Leuven in Belgium since completing
her PhD at the K you live in
she held multiple research positions
within and outside the University and
has published over 62 epic journal
papers focused around imaging lung
diseases and infections for a complete
biography on dr. van de Velde
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen professor van de
velvet over to you ok thank you very
much gel and hello everybody thanks for
having me I can see that you are many -
Logan thanks for that and yeah I hope I
can I can share some of my experience
with preclinical imaging with you and
also some of the enthusiasm that we
probably have a comment regarding a
small animal science so let me start by
illustrating a bit what the motivation
behind non-invasive imaging is in
general and it is us in general in many
of the preclinical research setups we
want to evaluate a disease model and
possibly also therapy and these are all
dynamic processes so things change and
progress and over time so that's our
time course and in a standard laboratory
experiment this is how it would go with
standard equipment you would have to
include different Mouse groups to cover
different time points to establish and
evaluate your pathology in the disease
model to look into the progression and
then in the next step maybe you want to
evaluate therapy and see how efficient
it is to cure your pathology and this
includes different Mouse groups or other
small animals at different time points
and a lot of work in a classic workup
which means taking out organs doing
histology or other ex-vivo analyses and
these are very useful in giving us
detailed information on cellular
interactions and so on but they're also
limited to a certain point in time it
excludes any idea on dynamics and as you
if you work with mice just like us you
will know that there's always some
variation between different animals and
that you often need to include many
animals or time points to overcome the
variation and to give a certain power to
your experiment and that is where I
think the biggest value of non-invasive
imaging comes in and at least that we
can do this to follow up a certain group
of mice individually over time at
different time points and in order to be
able to do that we need non-invasive
technology and that is what imaging
gives us let me maybe first take
something about us what we do so we're
in ribbon in Belgium and we are very
fortunate to be able to work in an
imaging facility which is called like
it's dead for molecular small animal
imaging center and it's indeed about
light in the sense that different
imaging modalities can really provide
different pieces of the puzzle so we
operate a bioluminescence imaging and
other optical imaging modalities such as
intravital microscopy we also operate
radionuclide imaging methods such like
such as pet and inspect and then we also
have imaging modalities that provide
more of anatomical and functional
context such as an ultrasound dedicated
to small animal imaging MRI scanners
also a bet mr for single day is that mr
and also a micro CT and the topic of
this webinar really revolve it around my
for City and it's to be honest it's one
of my favorite modalities because it's
just so versatile so I'm very eager to
tell you a little bit more about our
experience with that modality in this
webinar so to give a little bit of a
background so micro-ct
it stands for micro computed tomography
and for the ones less familiar with it
just a small introduction so in micro CT
scanner it basically exists out of an
x-ray source emitting x-rays and a
detector and then your object or your
mouse you want to image will be in the
middle and then the x-rays will actually
go through your object they will be
absorbed by different tissues that have
different densities to a different
extent along the way projecting an image
on the detector and if then the x-ray
source and the detector they turn around
the object they will after the imaging
has been done the computer will compute
a three-dimensional image out of all
these protections images so that's where
also the name computer tomography comes
from and then Micro actually refers to
the very yet small and micro range
resolution that a small animal and
dedicated small animal CT scanner can
provide for our research now it's very
graphically used as a current iteration
method and to give anatomical context to
and inspect images and extension city in
PET CT and SPECT ET and maybe you're
very familiar and you've seen a lot of
these types of images but micro CT can
do so much more than just providing
anatomical context to radionuclide
imaging methods for instance in our lab
these are the scanners we operate and so
micro CT at least for me it comes in two
flavors so on the one hand
you have like dedicated small animal
scanners that provide you with a very
high resolution for a rather small field
of view and it is just perfect for
imaging up to the level of the small
bones into a mouse and really provide
for detailed analysis of trabecular bone
etc also for for the lungs and the large
structure and a very high resolution and
then we also operate another scanner
which is very complementary to that and
that's actually also operates at a
higher resolution slightly less height
and the previous one over the low dose
but it has a large field of view
covering the entire mouth as you can see
in the exemplary images below that and
that's our workhorse for many
applications that involve longitudinal
imaging of tissue imaging as I also
illustrate in the next moment and these
two scanners are actually three and all
depends on what you want to do with it
so I hope to give you in what is about
to come some more insight in what you
can do with a micro CT in a practical
setting so to start and it is really one
of my favorite topics its lung imaging
and why do we like city so much for non
imaging that is at the lung
intrinsically gives a lot of contrast so
you can imagine so there's some soft
tissue around it belongeth consists of
air and aerated tissue and then Airways
and then blood vessels and they have
intrinsically very different densities
so with x-ray imaging this provides a
lot of intrinsic contrast so even
without any contrast agent City provides
you with very nice images of lung and
lung pathology and that's what you see
here for example for a lung fibrosis
model
simply amazing induced on fibrosis model
an air you see for a fiberoptic and a
healthy control mass the difference and
the types images we can get where you
can really see that the darker aerated
spaces in the lungs really get get
filled up with this fibrous tissue after
wood healing response upon grimacing
installation and then in the next step
based on the contrast difference between
aerated and non aerated lung tissue we
can segment out and binarize the images
so it means that we so all the white
pixels are the aerated content of the
lungs whereas all the black is all the
rest and out of that we can make 3d
models representing the aerated spaces
in the lung and this is a measure for
how much fibrosis and how thick if
animals are and this we can do
longitudinally so that's the power of
micro CT you can really follow up your
animals and follow up disease
progression week after week after week
and here you can see for instance that
week after week the fibrosis really
means that the might have less and less
aerated lung space to breathe and this
is a marker for disease and we cannot
only visualize this in 2d and in three
dimensions but we can also quantify this
and that's what you see here for
different groups and you can also
quantify the efficacy of a treatment
which is here illustrated by treatment
with imaginary bleomycin mice which
gives you the quantitative data and the
standard deviations which you need to
prove whether you're good and Xterra p
is working or not so this is also
powerful for other models of one
fibrosis and also very important here
illustrated by the work of my PhD
student gap that is that in this model
of fibrosis which is induced by silica
inhalation in the lungs and weekly scans
with
you can see on the scans that the mice
get very patchy areas of information and
later on fibrosis in the lungs and in
this model for instance it goes slowly
and it's also very long so if you want
to follow up Mike for a long period of
time and scan them every week you can
imagine that there's some that radiation
dose and cumulated radio radiation dose
is really something that we have to take
into account in the design of our
imaging methods and so that it's really
safe to scan the animals over and over
again with our micro CT and that is what
we can do with low dose micro CT and we
really demonstrate that this is valid to
follow up all different kind of laminate
and I listed on this slide some examples
that we have experience with and so if
this is applicable for your research
don't hesitate to ask me mind I will now
illustrate something more about a lung
infection as another example of the
power of micro CT that I want to
illustrate for you so the lung infection
I've been working on and we work on in
the lab laboratory is a cryptococcosis
infection it's a fungus that is inhaled
in the lung you can already see on the
left what healthy lungs look like on
city and on the right what these
infected lungs look like on CT and I
think you can really appreciate that
these lungs fill up with the fungal
growing in the lungs but the remarkable
thing is that you don't see anything
cells typically on the mice you don't
see any symptoms in these mice so only
micro City at that point in the
infection can give us an idea on the
extension of infection without having to
wait until the mice develop symptoms and
eventually succumb to the infection so
that's a very high power of the
methodology and it also refines our
experimental setup and reduces animal
suffering so a typical setup is that you
would weekly follow-up disease
progression and you
would really have the dynamics of
disease progression for every individual
Mouse that's what you see led us here so
these are weekly scans
where you really see the fungus growing
and the disease progressing in the lungs
and now we can quantify this similar as
to the fibrosis example we would
binarize based on an urbanization step
the aerated lung tissue from the
infected man tissue and here you would
see on this 2d image that the area of
lung spaces that are in white that they
really decrease over time and the
interesting thing is when we quantify
this for the entire lung then what you
see in the graph is that the air volume
in the lungs actually stays the same
over time so these are weekly time point
so up to six weeks after infection in
three dimensional analysis you don't see
it changes the airspace of the lungs
so if we then quantify other imaging the
right biomarkers such as the lesion
volume the volume of the infected tissue
by itself then you indeed see what's
what's obvious also from the visual
images that this that the volume of the
lesions increases week after week after
week for the infected mice and then
entreatingly you also see that the lungs
just get bigger and that's what you see
when we quantify the total lung volume
and we can quantify all these things
from the same micro CT scan that gives
us an idea what's actually happening in
the big knife seem to compensate somehow
for the infection load in lines so that
they still have enough air to breathe
and this is actually fascinating finding
that micro CT in able us to quantify it
image and then you can also quantify the
mean lung density as a biomarker CT
imaging derived biomarker of infections
to really follow progression and then
what I'd like to stress so this imaging
methods so we have the gold standard in
field of lung infection is often to
sacrifice your mouth take out the lungs
isolate them then homogenized
and played the homogenate for doing and
quantifying colony forming units in the
lungs to quantify your fungal burden in
the lungs and here I compared two sets
of mice scant with CT with the golden
standard so in panel B you see the
golden standard for two groups of mice
infected with 500 colony forming units
versus 50,000 so a smaller inoculum and
a larger inoculum and because there's a
high variation and high standard
deviation is coming from the unit
counting with this group of mice with
five miles and a bit more in a group we
do not have enough power to resolve the
differences specifically significant
difference to the groups whereas micro
city in panel a can which is illustrated
for two different biomarkers and we did
I want to illustrate that micro City has
a higher power and higher sensitivity
than the golden standard so we did even
message and I'd like to give that it's
really important to consider switching
to micro City to evaluate infectious
load in the noise I think it's a very
good technology and maybe well even
better than the golden standard but
really to discover you a challenge me on
that one
so a next thing on our micro CT images
is yet another biomarker that you can
extract from the same scans and for that
I need to say something about the way
that we deal with the imaging imaging
the motion and the respiratory movement
in the lungs so we actually acquire not
only a three-dimensional scan but you
can refer to it as a four-dimensional
scan because the fourth dimension would
then be the respiratory
movement over time and the way we do
this we do retrospective gating that
also means that we end up with images at
the end of expiration and also at the
end of inspiration and if you want to
find these sets of images and you
subtract them you can also extract the
dialogue volume which is a more
functional marker and if you spot it
here for the same lava cryptococcal
infected mice and you see over time that
you need a tidal volume so the volume
they have and use her breathing that it
remains the same and constant up to
later time points in infection and also
only when the infection is very much
progressed this tidal volume decreases
so this to illustrate yet another piece
of information we can get from micro CT
scans of the month but then there's
something peculiar about this infection
so a cryptococcal infection starts with
a lung infection and then at some point
also moves to the brain that's actually
part of our research but then when it
comes to imaging the brain infection
then we cannot do this with CT anymore
and then we have to rely on yet another
imaging method which is MRI to see the
brain and this is one image to
illustrate that if we have to find
cryptococcal lesions in the brain that
we do this with an MRI scan I indicated
to Indonesia that you can appreciate
following the yellow arrows and then why
is this and I want to illustrate and a
bit the difference is about CT and MRI
and I think what's important here to
take home as a message is that often I
get the question which imaging method is
better
is it is it an arai or something else
and very often the answer is never that
one or the other is better they're often
very complementary and where one imaging
method is good for a certain organ or
certain application maybe another one is
or something else and often we need them
both if we want to get a full picture of
these are the base model such as in the
previous example we need MRI to look at
the brain and CT to look at the lungs
and here I try to list them a little bit
of the list like how CT and MRI are
complementary and you can also see at
the images the CT is based on density
differences all the areas in the brain
and also the lesions they have a similar
density so a 60 image of the brain would
show a completely black image you have
no contrast there whereas MRI and if it
is strength of am right in that it
provides excellent soft tissue contrast
as you see the image so today in the
brain it doesn't give us this anatomical
information but it does give us a
fantastic contrast of the skull
whereas MRI on the other hand does not
give us any information so also if you
would want to image probes in the brain
50 would be much better than MRI sitting
as a much better resolution than the
right yeah that is when you need a high
resolution and 50 is also easy to use
where am writing is much more versatile
but this comes at the costal it's me it
may be more complex and it needs a bit
of a more expert user level to to really
get good quality scans out of it and
cities is relatively cheap compared to
MRI but basically and that's an
important thing I wanna message and I
want to confer that they're very often
complimentary and different images
imaging approaches often yeah overcome
limitations individual method so that's
why we often use CT MRI optical methods
in a multi modal imaging approach so
another example of how different
approaches like CT and MRI can be very
complementary I want to give in the next
example and in the next example we are
going to Barcelona so for one of my
postdocs I ended up in Barcelona and in
in and there were some colleagues
working on a very interesting research
and it's research what about Down
syndrome as it
published in 2014 there was a clinical
study that a green tea extract would
improve the cognitive death that the
cognitive deficits in Down syndrome and
on these people were working together
and looking into people with Down
syndrome and kids with Down syndrome and
after publication of this paper they
started taking this green tea extract in
the hope that it would improve the
cognition cognitive abilities of their
kids and when they were follow up
following up these people they had first
the impression that this was also
improving the typical facial traits of
these kids with Down syndrome and at
first it was an impression and then it
became more and more clear that maybe
this treatment with this green tea
extract could also improve the typical
facial trades in Down syndrome and
that's when where my colleague in
Barcelona dr. nails Martinez came into
the picture she took this set up to test
this hypothesis by investigating the
facial trace of these children so she's
looking so this is her research to look
into whether these green tea extract can
really make this improvement by
analyzing the poor and doing morphometry
on the faces of these kids treated with
the green tea extract and as I was there
and she explained about your research
which is really about testing and
comparing the facial shape of children
with Down syndrome and normal children
and then children treated with the green
tea extract therapy and so this is how
this is done and when you man
when you hear about trying to get good
imaging of the faces of little kids and
babies then everything concerning 50n
scan you might is the very image this is
different pictures are taken to a bit
like this to give you a little bit of
background on how this imaging
you get to then come up with these type
of results to really look that the
younger the kids are so here you see
different treatment groups that the
younger they are that the treated kids
which are the green dots they're
actually shifting towards from the
yellow dots which are kids with Down
syndrome towards the blue dots in the
facial Morpho space and this actually
means that the younger the kids are the
better the results seem to be but this
is an observational study and in order
to prove this we need to go to the
preclinical side and that's where I
could help a bit where we would look
into whether this green tea extract can
really really do something on the facial
shape and this makes sense because the
brain and the face of cognition and
neural development and the face are
obviously tightly integrated throughout
the development and growth etc and this
also illustrates that this often goes
together
cognitive deficits with some aberrant
facial development in very many other
different syndromes abortion dancing
Europe so we set out to investigate this
route down sit down
so to look into this maybe you're
familiar with this that Down syndrome is
trisomy of the chromosome 21 on this
chromosome 21 there's a critical region
for Down syndrome and here you find a
gene which is disc one a and this gene
is one a modulated by this green tea
extract so our hypothesis is that the
treatment could make sense in the sense
that when there's too much of this disc
on a when the gene region is triplicated
in down syndrome that when the green tea
extract may be dis can inhibit disc to a
more normal level so in order to test
this hypothesis we set up to do this on
mice and there's a mouse model for Down
syndrome and then we
we can scan them with both CT and MRI
and that's what we did here in
Louisville with the team and mice you
can make really controlled experimental
settings and then we looked together
with nails colleagues here as the brain
shape and also at the skull shape and
you already see me coming that for
looking at brain and at the bones we
need two bodies MRI and CT that worked
better so this is a bit what we did we
breed the mind we have different groups
treated with the green tea extract not
treated mice with Down syndrome and just
normal mice and then we scan them so
just to say something on what we can get
with MRI you when we scan the with MRI
this cannon from when they're really
small
three days after birth when the mice
develop until adulthood at 29 days of
age and we'll get this typical mr image
and from this one of our image and
that's what our Purdue student says she
is doing we can do different types of
analyses so for instance we can segment
the ventricles and quantified the volume
which is important in Down syndrome
because patients with Down syndrome they
have larger ventricles and we can also
look at the size of the whole brain and
then surgery also analyzes the center
belem to quantify all these biomarkers
that we can extract from an MRI scan so
that's for the brain analyses and then
there's even a step further to even go
to more detailed analyses of the brain
and if morphometric analysis just to
give you an idea so different dogs
different landmarks are placed at
specific anatomical locations so this is
from a publication and when we would do
this on our scan and that's what session
is doing you really places the dots on
the scans that we have from the Down
syndrome mice and from these dogs
different measures can be taken and they
can all be analyzed and this is really
not my expertise
expertise of nails and surgery that too
very detailed morphometric analysis but
it's amazing with all these landmarks
how much information we can get out of
the brain so we can really analyze based
on a few metric morphometrics come up
with this type of data data on shape on
size on bending so really on the
differences in brain anatomy that are
typical in Down syndrome and then
obviously we can also in a very
quantitative manner evaluate whether the
treatment normalizes this and has a
beneficial effect on this or not so
that's the researcher is currently
conducting with the help of our MRI
imaging now there's not only a MRSA lab
also scanning the mice in parallel with
our micro CT and because we follow up
the mice from really day three after
development d-minor in full development
so it's really essential to have a low
dose protocol and we have developed and
optimized this with our micro CT scanner
so that there's definitely no influence
of the radiations to these mice that we
don't have that we don't induce any
difference colleges just by scanning so
we can follow this up with our protocol
and even though we have to compromise a
bit on image quality so that the
protocol is low-dose the images are of a
very high quality that allows us to
evaluate very many different days so for
instance we can analyze the effect of
the treatment on the mice so you see
here volume rendered images from from
our scan of the skull that we can
analyze the face and the effect of the
treatment on the face and we're very
high detail we can do more full
morphological visual assessment of any
developmental errors as you
different examples here throughout
development for normal mice versus dance
in your mind and we can really detect
and pick up differences due to phenotype
and also due to the treatment in
different doses we can also look at with
the same morphometric approach which is
the expertise of my colleague knows that
by putting different landmarks and the
quality of the scan is high enough that
we can identify the different anatomical
landmarks to put in great detail these
these these and identify this
morphometric points on the skull and
also on the mandible and this again
allows us to evaluate for the skull and
the mandible what you see here at
different ages of mine are scanned at
different ages really see how the
differences between genotype and also
treatment these people and here for
instance you see that based on this type
of data we can we can conclude that the
Down syndrome is activity is smaller
this is very typical and also that very
high dose treatment can make this makes
even smaller and then we also have lower
dose treatment that's not illustrated
here in every community that this effect
is much better and the treatment can
even improve it so this to illustrate
that this technique allows us to assess
all these things in the mass mall
experimentally and just to say that this
is a type of data that we can extract
out of it so for different time points
really truly longitudinal data on the
evolution of this different large group
that you see in the different colors and
then you can really see upon treatment
whether the group shift more towards the
welcome phenotype or the down syndrome
phenotype and then in this way we can
analyze in great detail whether the
treatment works or not and identify side
effects and really optimize the dose of
the bench
treatment save also for the medical
that's illustrated here and so if you
want to see more and also comment on we
published our our first details on the
experiments on the facial morphology and
the treatment here so you can access
this online and also comment on it and
give us some feedback on our work but
not only regarding the skull interface
but because we actually take whole body
scans
there's so much more that we can get out
of the same micro CT scan and it also
gives us more information on the full
skeletal development in Down syndrome
and frieza this is relevant because also
people with Down syndrome they have
shorter typically shorter arms and legs
and they all types of problems with
mineralization of the bones and also
this we can evaluate from the same scan
so we can see size we can measure shape
but also important biomarkers such as
big bone mineral density that are
relevant to our animal model not only
that it also from the appendicular
skeleton the same size and shape
analysis can be done in high resolution
with putting the anatomical landmarks
and our micro CT data allows us to do
that so we get as you can see below we
can have detailed quantitative more
symmetrical analysis that allows us to
make conclusions on the efficacy of the
treatment also on the humerus the
scapula and other bones of the
appendicular skeleton so to wrap up for
me what makes me such a fan of micro CT
is that it's a relatively simple
technology it works really well a
scanning super fast but you can get so
much information and biomarkers out of
it so with one single low-dose hold on
america CT scan we can get information
and landmarking and morphometric
analysis for the skull and the face we
can also get a monitor very so
and changes by throughout development
and also upon modulation by drugs that
interfere with development we can get
all the information about skeletal
development for the whole body and all
the bone in there and we can also do
along with internal shape analysis on
the same knife and we work with
transgenic animals this is very valuable
if you don't have to sacrifice so many
animals but you could just follow the
same animals over time so this is for me
the high power and what really helps us
all of us working with mice in our in
our experiments so I have many people to
thank because this is I'm not doing this
on my own so these are our teams very
grateful to work in such dynamic teams
thanks everybody also thanks for the
slides and the images and the help and
the result that I was able to present
here and also the funding there's room
for some more and then I will say to you
that if you are thinking about the
limiting approach that you're not sure
comfortable feel free to discuss we're
so happy to help because we're happy
that the non-invasive imaging helps us a
lot in our research and we're glad to
share with the whole scientific
community so now it's your turn
feel free to ask and really curious
about all the questions that you may
have and I hope I'll be able to answer
them thank you very much for listening
thank you for festival velvet for your
informative presentation so if you have
any question you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as possible and now
also give you a moment to participate in
our survey while we review the incoming
questions we'll be back in a minute
you
hi again and let's start with with the
Q&A session so dr. von the ballad the
first question would be what was the
resolution used to scan the skull we use
scans at 50 micron isotropic resolution
and it already gives us a very good
result that enable us to do all the
analyses as I showed here
all right thank you we have a second one
coming up some people don't seem to have
access to such scanners how would they
be able to get access to such imaging
equipment well try to convince your
price to buy you one but has it not so
obvious um so um you should take a look
around because there are many
initiatives and many labs that may have
it scanner so regarding city I would
recommend to check the dentists in your
institution or in your city and bone
people because maybe they have a CT
already there because for that it's much
longer a standard equipment and they're
probably happy to share their device
with you also at least in Europe and
also this also comes for our facility
they are set up as a sort of open
platform you can always contact us and
also other equipment in for instance the
euro bio imaging initiative where you
can have access to different imaging
centers just like ours across Europe try
to find the Machine that you need the
expertise you need for setting up
collaborations so for instance you can
also always contact us we're also very
happy to collaborate if we are able to
help for your specific question and help
you find maybe by our colleagues to find
imaging equipment what you can also do
is to contact a vendor princess you can
contact broker and ask them if they know
we're colleagues in your neighborhood or
your country have a machine and put you
in contact with colleagues and in my
experience even people are always happy
to share the Machine for all the time
that they're not using it so I hope that
that is somehow already useful to get
you to have access to scanning equipment
in while your life or something
get your own and have it close by for
centering application yeah all right how
about this one we saw that that micro
City was used for for scanning bones for
scanning lung are there any other
applications which are possible with
micro CT of course and I think we
haven't explored them all so from my
start with my own experience and the
things that we do here at mosaic is that
we also use micro CT to monitor
metabolic diseases for instance to look
at body composition and micro CT is also
very good in discerning fat from solid
organs and soft tissues and the lungs
etc so fat quantification is a very yeah
very much used application you can also
use it to do cardiac imaging and cardiac
functional imaging that also works very
well but there you do need to work with
a contrast agent but these are all
commercially available and you can
combine that with yeah you have the
whole body scan so we combined it with
pulmonary scans we do that in one go
other things that we've been looking at
the bladder with micro CT by filling the
bladder with a contrast agent we've also
been looking at bowel infections well
you can always browse and Google and
there are more and more discs coming up
and often people just come here to say
like look we have a biological question
we have this animal model can we what
can we do and then this is my favorite
part of the job let me push sit down and
brainstorm
and then we see our maybe this way we
can do it with micro-ct and maybe dare
them or I can help or another approach
and we always come up with a cool idea
to make it work if we have one more so
that the scan is one part of the job but
after that they tend to be reconstructed
data need to be analyzed how difficult
is it to process and quantify such data
ha yeah that's a very very relevant
question so regarding image acquisition
so there you need to know a bit about
the nuts and both because an image you
can have a super good machine with an
image is only as good as the person
knowing about the parameters and the
person using the machine but once you
have your image acquired you also want
to quantify and do things and when you
look in literature you will see that
people have custom written algorithms
and things that you think ok I have no
easy access to it I'm not a software
engineer how do I do that and it is also
something that in our approach that we
try to keep simple and doable to find
something that is robust and that any
biomedical scientist anybody working
with animals can do by themselves and
then we just use the software provided
by the manufacturer that is delivered
together with the with the scanner and
that really gives us all the software we
need for visualization but also for
processing and it even allows us to
build custom processing algorithms for
dummies if I can stay that way that even
if you're not a programmer you could
really build something that works for
your life so that's really nice and also
for instance to give an example the way
we analyze a lot but that's something
quite easy to do it's a bit
time-consuming because we manually
delineate the lungs but once you have
that it's very easy to extract all the
biomarkers the morphometric analysis
that's of course a bit more tedious and
this is really especially them and for
that I'm really lucky to collaborate
with news that's really her expert
so if you want to do that you can find a
collaborator that's expert expert in
that but apart from that there is a lot
that you can do just with the software
delivered with it and the freely
available software like Fenian image J
and so on so I what you have to keep in
mind is indeed that image acquisition is
one thing but you probably spend a bit
more time on the data processing but
even taking all that into account if you
compare it with an standard workup like
astrology sacrificing animals staining
doing microscopy it's so much easier and
faster compared to that so let's data
processing not scare you away that's
what I would like you to remember
mentioning the faster process can you
give us an idea about how long scans
typically take I depends on the
application so for instance if you have
a very quick scan just to have total
body anatomy then you can you can you
can get away with in scanning eight
seconds for instance but for the more
higher-end safety applications as the
ones I outlined here it takes a bit
longer because you want to scan at a
better resolution so for the dancing
demise I think we're at three minutes
scan definitely not longer and for the
last scan it depends you can also scan
to a very good long scan at three
minutes but if you want the four
dimensional lung scan which means that
you have n scan at end of expiration
inspiration so that you can extract
functional information then you are
looking at ten minutes
scan so dependability all right thanks
again for festival Nevada before we'd
like to go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker through
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration and
if you miss the participating in our
survey will pop up again on your screen
at the end of this presentation your
feedback is important to us so thanks
for participating I would like to thank
again professor thon Valda for her time
today and her import important research
we would also like to thank laugh roots
and our sponsor broker for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through December
2018 laugh routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that ebook your
colleagues who may have missed today's
life event until next time goodbye